en el último vídeo vimos porque
cualquier número que querramos dividirlo
entre 0 es matemáticamente dicho que
está indefinido pero supongo que en tu
cabeza te has estado planteando la
siguiente pregunta qué pasa en el caso
de cuando se divide 0 entre 0 este no es
un argumento que podría estar definiendo
nuestra pregunta entonces vamos a lo
siguiente
pensemos en ceros sobre 0 cuál sería el
par de líneas de razonamiento por aquí
entonces podríamos comenzar tomando
números o valores muy muy cercanos a
cero y dividirlos entre sí mismos como
por ejemplo si tomamos 0.01 y lo
dividimos sobre sí mismo nos da igual a
uno luego un número más pequeño 0.01
también dividido sobre si es igual a uno
un número más pequeño 20.0000 uno sobre
sí mismo también va a ser igual a uno y
luego entonces decimos lo siguiente no
nos importa que dichos números fueran
negativos aquí cambiamos los signos pues
nos sigue arrojando el mismo resultado
así que basado en esta lógica
podríamos decir y esto suena como un
excelente argumento para poder decir que
es 0 sobre 0 está definido igual a 1
entonces ponemos por aquí que 0 sobre 0
es igual a 1 en sonaría bastante lógico
pero ahora viene lo siguiente que de
repente alguien viniera y te dijera
bueno pues ahora qué pasaría si
dividimos 0 entre números muy cercanos a
0 no un número sobre sí mismo pero sí
sobre números muy pequeños o números muy
cercanos a 0 y entonces que tomáramos
por ejemplo 0 sobre 0.1 esto es igual a
0 0 sobre todavía uno más pequeño 0.01
también va a ser igual a cero y cero
sobre cero punto 0 0001 y también va a
ser igual a cero entonces también está
este argumento o esta lógica nos
acompaña a decir que aunque pongamos
negativos nos sigue arrojando el mismo
resultado y con esto pensamos que 0
sobre 0 también podemos decir que es
igual a 0 y entonces tenemos por igual
dos argumentos válidos y porque ambos
son igualmente válidos
se dice que es inconsistente dentro de
las matemáticas por lo que una vez más
matemáticamente se ha dejado que 0 sobre
0 está indefinido 0 sobre 0 se dice
entonces que está indefinido